North Korea issued a new threat to
attack the American territory of Guam at
a stern warning from President Trump the
regime says it could use missiles to
create an envelope encoder Western
Pacific island the u.s. territory just
over 2,000 miles from North Korea is
home to a hundred and sixty-two thousand
people more than six thousand American
troops are stationed there to b1 bombers
based in Guam flew over the Korean
Peninsula in a show of force on Monday
President Trump issued a stark warning
yesterday after news leaked of a US
intelligence assessment that the North's
nuclear weapons program has passed
another milestone best not make any more
threats to the United States
they will be met with fire and fury like
the world has never seen David Martin is
at the Pentagon David good morning good
morning the Pentagon has not yet
responded to North Korea's latest threat
but it comes as a new intelligence
estimate says the north has prostate
critical threshold in developing a
nuclear weapon capable of hitting the
United States
the estimate by the Pentagon's Defense
Intelligence Agency concludes North
Korea can build a nuclear weapon small
enough to fit atop a ballistic missile
capable of reaching the United States a
device similar to one Kim jong-un showed
off more than a year ago that photo-op
is now considered a reality and it drew
a stark warning from President Trump
best not make any more threats to the
United States they will be met with fire
and fury like the world has never seen
last month North Korea launched two
missiles high into space which had they
been fired on a lower trajectory would
have had the range to reach parts of the
US but government officials and outside
experts say North Korea has yet to
demonstrate two key technologies needed
for a reliable nuclear weapon a nose
cone that can shield the nuclear warhead
from the extreme heat and buffeting of
reentering the atmosphere and a guidance
system to steer it accurately toward its
target earlier this summer the Defense
Intelligence Agency estimated North
Korea would solve those problems and
have a reliable weapon as early as next
year a full two years earlier than
previously forecast we're on a very
dangerous course and the two sides need
to get on to the off-ramp Darryl Kimball
is director of the arms Control
Association what North Korea is
concerned about or American military
threats they're only going to strike out
if they feel threatened the crisis over
North Korea's nuclear weapons program
has been building slowly for years
dating back to the Clinton
administration it now appears that one
way or the other it will come to a head
during the Trump administration Margaret
David thank you